veamos cómo afecta la eliminación de
todos a los compuestos cíclicos
empecemos con uno simple
aquí he dibujado la conformación de
silla para el ciclo hexano en la que aún
no he dibujado los enlaces
recuerden empezamos con el carbono 1 y
vamos hacia arriba en posición axial
entonces justo aquí vamos hacia arriba y
luego alternamos cuando nos movemos al
carbono 2 vamos hacia abajo aquí tenemos
dos sustituciones axiales no dibujar el
resto de la molécula porque solo quiero
que nos enfoquemos en el lado derecho
entonces el siguiente es ecuatorial y
como empezamos con axial arriba nos
vamos hacia abajo ecuatorial hacia abajo
y después solo alternamos entonces aquí
es ecuatorial hacia arriba eso es todo
lo que necesitamos dibujar en este
pequeño ejemplo ahora pondré un cloro
arriba del carbono 1 como pueden
imaginar los demás enlaces se unen a
hidrógenos en este anillo
queremos hacer reaccionar este ciclo
hexano con el tóxico de sodio que es
nuestra base en esta reacción recuerden
cuando llevamos a cabo una reacción de
eliminación éstos necesitamos tener una
conformación anti peri planar así que
necesitamos ver la molécula de forma
anti peri planar para poder identificar
el carbono e hidrógeno beta primero
encontremos nuestro carbono alfa aquí
está unido al cloro
este es nuestro carbono alfa y nuestro
carbono beta sería el que está a un lado
este de aquí es el carbono beta
ahora en el carbono beta hay un
hidrógeno hacia abajo que se encuentra
en el mismo plano que el cloro por lo
que este es el protón que participará en
la reacción y el cloro como nuestro
grupo saliente debe estar axial para
poder tener la conformación anti peri
planar otra cosa que hay que observar es
que esto se ve como una proyección de
caballete como en los vídeos anteriores
mientras dibuja vamos el mecanismo si
recalcamos estos enlaces podemos ver
fácilmente la proyección de caballete
espero que la puedan ver para dibujar el
producto tenemos que involucrar a
nuestra base electos y do de sodio que
toma este protón y así estos electrones
se mueven para formar el doble enlace
entre el carbono alfa y beta al mismo
tiempo estos electrones se irán con el
grupo saliente es decir
en la posición axial nos queda un doble
enlace formándose entre el carbono 1 y
el carbono 2 así que donde sea que lo
quieran poner no importa al final nos
queda el ciclo externo esa es la idea
solo busquen la conformación anti peri
plana con el grupo saliente en posición
axial hagamos uno más complicado para
ahorrar tiempo he dibujado dos con
formaciones de silla para el cloruro de
miau mentido en vídeos anteriores pueden
aprender a dibujar estas con formaciones
ahora nos interesa saber cuál de estas
dos con formaciones es más estable
también hablamos de eso en uno de los
vídeos anteriores vimos que al poner los
grupos más voluminosos en la posición
ecuatorial la molécula es más estable
hay menor dificultad estética entonces
es la conformación de la derecha es más
estable aquí está el grupo hizo propio
en la posición ecuatorial
el grupo metil
y esto convierte al cloro en axial esta
será la conformación mayor y por lo
tanto esta sería la menor porque los
grupos más voluminosos como el grupo
metilo y el liso propio están en
posición axial y eso desestabiliza de
alguna manera entonces la conformación
mayor es la de la derecha y en esa es en
la que nos vamos a enfocar porque el
cloro está en posición axial y
necesitamos que así esté el grupo
saliente ahora identifiquemos nuestro
carbono alfa
este es nuestro carbono alfa le pondré
números así será más fácil digamos que
este es el carbono 1
este es el carbono 2 carbono 3 y carbono
4 entonces este es el carbono 1 este es
el 2 carbono 3 y este es el 4 nuestros
posibles carbonos beta son el carbono 1
y 3 1 y 3 afortunadamente hay un
hidrógeno en ambos carbonos si
observamos de cerca podemos ver que
cualquiera de los dos está anti peri
planar con respecto al cloro entonces si
la base entra es decir el stock sido de
sodio entra al mecanismo dibujemos la
molécula el tóxico de sodio está cargado
negativamente tomará a este protón
dejando a los electrones que se moverán
para formar el doble enlace al mismo
tiempo que el cloro se va dibujemos lo
que nos queda si esta reacción ocurre
área un poco de espacio el doble enlace
se forme entre el carbono 2 y el carbono
tres si dibujamos el producto nos queda
el grupo iso propio hacia nosotros y
estos son el carbono 2 y carbono 3 si la
numeración del anillo es 1 2 3
y 4 el doble enlace se forma entre las
posiciones 2 y 3 y luego tenemos el
grupo metilo hacia abajo en el carbono 4
este es un posible producto recuerden
que también tenemos a este protón que
pasaría ahora la base toma este protón
que también es anti peri planner y si
eso sucede estos electrones se moverán
para formar un doble enlace entre el
carbono 1 y 2 y estos electrones se irán
con el grupo saliente en la posición
axial esta también es una posibilidad y
que nos quedaría bueno dibujemos el
producto aquí está otra vez el grupo
isopropílico en el carbono 1 esta vez no
hay estéreo química asociada al grupo
propio porque el doble enlace se forme
entre el carbono 1 y el 2
veremos los carbonos este es uno dos
tres y cuatro el doble enlace se forme
entre el carbono 1 y el carbono 2 porque
este hidrógeno el protón sale en este
mecanismo lo que cambia el estado de
hibridación sp3 del carbono beta a esp 2
entonces este carbono tiene una
hibridación sp2 todo es plano así que no
hay estéreo química es por eso que no
puse una barra solamente dibuje una
línea recta hay estéreo química asociada
pero con el grupo metilo que aún está
lejos de nosotros entonces tenemos dos
posibles productos cuál de estos dos se
producirá en mayor cantidad
bueno hay que pensar sobre la
estabilidad de un al que no del lado
izquierdo
tenemos un al que no he sustituido justo
aquí en el doble enlace hay dos grupos r
y para el ejemplo de la derecha
en el doble enlace hay tres grupos r es
un el que no es sustituido que lo
convierte en el producto mayor porque
como ya sabemos los al que nos 3
sustituidos son más estables y el al que
no y sustituido será el producto menor
para esta reacción hay dos posibles
productos y todo se trata de poder
dibujar la conformación de silla y
entender la relación de la conformación
anti peri planar entre el protón y el
grupo saliente hagamos uno más el
cloruro de metilo muy parecido al
cloruro de no mentí lo veamos las dos
conformación es sencilla para el cloruro
de metilo para ahorrar tiempo ya las he
dibujado para ustedes pero pueden ver
los vídeos anteriores para entender cómo
se hacen si observamos estas con
formaciones cuál de las dos es más
estable hay que observar si el grupo más
voluminoso está en la posición axial o
ecuatorial
a la derecha nuestro grupo metilo está
ecuatorial y el cloro está ecuatorial
todo está ecuatorial aquí esta es la
conformación más estable porque en la
otra tenemos a los grupos más
voluminosos en la posición axial el
grupo metilo está axial el cloro está
axial y el grupo isopropílico está axial
que opinan cuál de estas conformaciones
será la más importante en nuestro
mecanismo bueno el grupo saliente tiene
que estar en la posición axial entonces
sería nuestra conformación menor porque
el grupo saliente está axial ahora
identifiquemos a nuestro carbono alfa
este es nuestro carbono alfa y
necesitamos protones beta bueno este es
un posible beta y este es otro veamos
primero el de la derecha el grupo pro
pilot está hacia arriba obviamente no
puede participar en el mecanismo
cuando hay un hidrógeno aquí porque el
protón no está anti peri planar entonces
este carbono beta no participa en
ninguna reacción pero el otro carbono
beta tiene a este hidrógeno que está en
la conformación anti peri planar junto
con el cloro nuestro grupo saliente
entonces este será el único protón que
participará en el mecanismo como nos
queda nuestro producto bueno dibujemos a
nuestra base el avión de led óxido de
sodio entra en el mecanismo está cargado
negativamente y toma a éste protón que
deja estos electrones para que formen el
doble enlace al mismo tiempo que el
cloro se va enumeremos nuestros carbonos
digamos que él hizo propio es uno
y 4 entonces este es uno dos tres y
cuatro el doble enlace se formará entre
nuestros carbonos 2 y 3 dibujemos el
producto aquí se forma el doble enlace
entre los carbonos 2 y 3 y tenemos al
grupo isopropílico hacia nosotros
tenemos aquí el carbono 1 2 3 y 4
enumeremos tenemos al carbono 1 2 3 y 4
sabemos que el doble enlace se forma
entre carbono 2 y 3 y luego tenemos el
grupo metilo hacia abajo en el carbono 4
así queda nuestro producto este es el
único producto porque sólo hay un protón
anti peri planar para este mecanismo así
que tenemos dos saludos de al kilo cada
uno obtenido por la reacción de
eliminación el 2 ahora la pregunta es
cuál de estos saludos de alquilo
reaccionará más rápido la respuesta
tiene que ver con la estabilidad de la
conformación para el cloruro de metilo
para este ejemplo el cloro se encuentra
en la posición axial pero es la
conformación menor por lo que gran parte
de la molécula se acomodará para la
conformación mayor así que este alumno
del kilo
será lento para una reacción de
eliminación de dos porque la mayor parte
del tiempo el cloro no está en la
conformación que necesitamos pero ocurre
todo lo contrario para el cloruro de
neón ventiló la mayor parte del tiempo
en el caso del cloruro de neo ventiló se
tiene al grupo saliente como axial en la
conformación mayor por lo que el cloruro
de metilo es más rápido para una
reacción de eliminación de dos alrededor
de 200 veces más rápida que una reacción
de eliminación de dos para el cloruro de
metilo y como les decía todo se trata de
las conformaciones y de cuál es la más
estable como vimos la relación anti peri
planar es lo más importante
cuando se hacen mecanismos de 2